mais route meurtri après les explosions
souffrait déjà d'une hausse historique
du coût de la vie et de la dévaluation
sans précédente sa monnaie la livre
libanaise
le petit marché de bassam était souvent
déserts même avant les explosions les
ventes ont chuté de 60% les rares
clients n'achètent plus que de l'eau et
des cigarettes 500 maintenant elle est
de 2500 ça a bien augmenté cinq fois
donc les gens n'achètent beaucoup moins
oui les gens n'achètent plus il assure
voir les riches qui achètent maintenant
le liban et porte 80% de sa nourriture
et l'achète en dollars américains avec
la dépréciation de la livre libanaise
tout coûte 4 à 5 fois plus cher des
choix s'imposent pour tous les libanais
même les plus fortunés ya j'ai été
acheté de la viande et moi je me
considère assez à l'aise par rapport à
d'autres les gens et je voulais un kilo
et demi a acheté une de mes kilos à
cause du prix et encore je dis moi j'ai
acheté de la viande il y en a d'autres
qui n'achètent plus du tout pour
survivre de nombreux libanais se
tournent maintenant vers l'étranger ils
dépendent de l'argent que des proches
vivant au canada ou aux états unis par
exemple le renvoi pour tenter d'aider à
passer à travers cette crise économique
les filles sont souvent longues pour
obtenir ces transferts internationaux
à tel point que western union ne peut
répondre qu'à 250 clients par jour à
cette succursale pour une troisième
journée de suite cet homme n'a pas
réussi à obtenir les 1000 dollars
envoyés par son frère médecin au new
jersey il devra revenir demain les
portes closes se multiplient devant les
boutiques de beyrouth
l'économie du pays est miné par des
décennies de dépenses exagérées et de
corruption la dette publique libanaise
avoisine les 150 % du pib un taux
semblable à celui de la grèce lors de la
crise en europe espoirs ultime remporté
la loterie pour quitter cette vie
pichard rêve depuis trente ans de
remporter le gros lot est d'amener sa
famille au canada
une poétesse a dit que beyrouth est
mille fois morte et mille fois revécu
après la double explosion meurtrière
elle devra renaître dans un pays au bord
du gouffre économique et c'est philippe
leblanc au canada beyrouth